Toria of the many shows that you've been
involved with which is the one that
taught you the greatest lesson about
this industry and what was it I'd have
to say that if I look back over
everything that I've done in 20 plus
yikes series now flipping out probably
is the best example of a fully rounded
cast and a well-integrated story I've
been really really it's just
exceptionally proud of that show they
did one season I did the very first
season and the tone that we were able to
set the cast was wonderful I mean
there's still some of my favorite people
to watch but what I learned about that
is how to give people that 3-dimensional
feeling that you that you know a
character you're not just selecting the
content that is the loudest or the
noisiest or the most explosive you have
again highs and lows and peaks and
valleys and that's how you tell a story
you can't just be constantly hammering
people with noise and that's followed me
forward it's helped me through
basketball wives it's helped me through
lots of the shows that I've done most of
the time I'm involved with the show a
little bit during production remotely
because I tend to work from a post
position where I'm sort of forensic ly
putting story together based on what's
coming from the field and trying to make
sense of what's been shot flipping out
was the best toolkit I could have
possibly ever had to put that together
as far as sheer learning experiences The
Osbournes The Osbournes I was working as
a dailies coordinator for them that
basically I was supporting the story
department if you go to IMDB and you
look up the people who were in the story
Department on that show you have sue
kolinsky who is a credit an incredible
writer you have Henry at Mantell who's a
great comic performer in addition to
being a great writer
you have Jeff Stilson who had worked on
the Galleon G show you
of Melanie Graham who was running the
whole story Department who had written
for SML and some other things these are
all people who understand story and
humor and how to dig it out of that
material and I learned it was like going
to college working with that bunch so
it's kind of a split I learned a lot I
learned a lot from flipping out but I
learned a lot from The Osbournes as well
you